bruce arians has and i don't want to
call it a strategy it's just the way he
is
bruce arians is the way he is bill
belichick is the way he is
bill belichick would never call out one
of his players publicly
bruce arians has called out the great
and powerful tom brady
twice in consecutive days yes after the
loss to the saints
and then he went in on him again
yesterday again yesterday let's hear a
little bit
of bruce arians talking about brady's
performance in his first game as a
buccaneer
he's had it before i mean he knows how
to bounce back and uh
he knew he didn't play very well and uh
it's not what he expects from himself
nor do we expect so i wouldn't
anticipate him to
have a little more grit and a little
more determination this week
and there's even more from erin's where
he said you know i was surprised based
on what i saw in practice i thought he
was going to be better
the day before the the two interceptions
we played that
sound yesterday blaming the
interceptions on tom brady
yeah talked about the first drive said
hey we were in sequence then you can't
say we weren't ready to go because we
showed that we were ready to go
and then took even i thought a little
another like and then we don't get any
more chunk plays after that which i
thought was a little even
slight shade towards brady there once
again so
i i don't it's this is going to be
interesting to watch here
because you're right it's a totally
different environment for tom brady he's
used to being coached hard and called
out and things like that
but never in the media never so just
hard on my sleeve i'm bruce arians and
you ask me the question i answer it i
love that about bruce but this is going
to be different for tom
and uh i'll you know a few more bumps in
the road i'll be interested to see where
this goes but
those are pretty like when he says i
think he'll show more
grit and determination and that was
that's again that's
pretty strong language for a guy that's
showed a lot of grit and determination
you know again i'm just questioning i'm
talking to you is he saying he didn't
think it was gritty and determined
enough
last sunday you know i mean that's the
way i think a little bit right
so yeah uh i'm it's i'm perked up now
going oh well okay bruce erin's tom
brady keep my eye on this
and here's the reality with bruce arians
and look i'm not criticizing him because
i am far more like bruce arians than not
like bruce arians
he didn't become a coach a head coach
until 2013 in part because he doesn't
play the game
he doesn't kiss ass that's right doesn't
say what he's supposed to say when he's
supposed to say it
he says what he thinks and it's going to
be an interesting experiment
to see how tom brady reacts to a setting
where for 20 years he was coached hard
and criticized and called out
behind the scenes but never called out
publicly
by his head coach to now he's in a spot
where
he's going to get it wherever he gets it
and bruce aaron's is going to give it to
him and i'm
bruce ahrens is saying this stuff
publicly he's saying it to his face
he's not going to be afraid to tell tom
brady where he needs to get better how's
tom going to react to it
if it happens again and again at what
point does brady start giving it back a
little bit
at what point is there maybe a comment
about well the offense isn't where it
needs to be i don't think brady's wired
that way
yeah right but aryans is wired his way
yes and this is what brady signed on for
it's what he wanted so it's
it's hard for him to complain about it
especially early on
well yeah in the process yeah i think
you're i think you're right and if brady
plays well let's just set it straight
like bruce will i mean just gush about
him
you know he will that's what he does if
you play well he's going to have his arm
around you and tell you
my quarterback's the greatest thing
we've ever seen since sliced bread he's
unbelievable
but when you lose and do what you did
the other day and brady yeah it was a
little all over the place especially for
tom brady uh bruce doesn't hold back
and and if it did happen mike to answer
your question
i think at some point brady would would
probably have to like go in and have a
private talk with bruce arians you're
right i don't think brady's wired
to take a shot publicly or do something
like that
he might have to go in and just say hey
cut the crap you got a problem with my
play
i understand you could say i didn't play
well but
let's talk about it we don't need to air
out every play of every game and have
everybody dissecting everything
but then aryan says can't you take it if
you can't take that
how are you supposed to stand up to
these guys who are chasing you around
who are half your age
true i mean true you're right that's
gonna be
a valid response and and everything
about that to where
that's where tom will have to be
tactical maybe tom just gotta let it
shrug off his shoulder then
and show that none of this helps him and
just keep fighting for now
put your head down and realize hey it's
still the early phases of this offense
mike evans wasn't 100
i didn't play my best game certainly and
we played a really good defense in the
new orleans saints
and let's just build on it and i think
that's the approach brady will take i
mean i don't expect him to be
too you know ruffled feathers
you know pissed off quite yet i think
he's just gonna be pissed by his play
and kind of
try to rebound from from that standpoint
i can hear harry and sin if this is what
you wanted baby you wanted to come play
for us you
you you want to have a head coach who's
not going to say when you stink you
should have stayed in new england i
could
i could hear him saying it i i i don't
doubt
well listen it may not come to that
though it's just one game
it may be the toughest game they play
all year that's right it's just one game
and we'll see where it goes
i know i had a lot of like boston
friends
sunday night and monday night going man
for the last 12 years
all we wanted to know was at brady or
belichick and
you know as far as week one concerned
that question was kind of answered
pretty harshly or pretty directly right
there
and this will continue to be the
conversation all year long brady
belichick and we'll see the ebbs and
flows and where it goes
all right mr jaworski you watched the
film what was your take on tom brady's
first performance with the team
other than the patriots well let's let's
be realistic like like we just said
first off the offense is a work in
progress
second off it was a really good defense
they're playing
you know third of all they couldn't run
the football
a lick really so that's not fun to be
playing in that
new offense new scheme oh i can't get
any pressure off me and get a run game
going
therefore play action doesn't work
anything like that
so it was a team effort that was a
little
underwhelming across the board and
brady's play
overall yeah it's underwhelming were
there some big time throws yes there was
a few of them certainly
but i think the two interceptions were
clearly his fault the first
one down the middle to mike evans i know
there was a little miscommunication but
aaron's told us
evan's read it right you know brady kind
of just panicked to get the pocket
started to collapse
and that's another part of being in a
new offense you know the pocket
collapses
you know in new england he could
probably just picture where everybody is
with his eyes closed like
oh man the pocket's collapsing i know
where i could throw the ball out of my
hands or
get it to a back and just not get an
intentional grounding this offense he
might still be thinking about stuff like
that
so he panics he throws it high down to
mike evans interception
not a good throw not a good decision the
next one mike
is a screenplay to the left the screen
is there
i don't know what to do so norris
jenkins the genorus jenkins pick six
right and i don't know
what brady was looking at
uh to not throw the screen either way he
had the out
route but he was a little late throwing
it and as you saw or anybody saw
highlights or the game itself
he threw it three or four feet behind
him and janoris jenkins made a great
break and
pick six hi i'm mike tarico and thanks
for watching
make sure to hit subscribe for the
latest news and highlights
from nbc sports